This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. I have a question for you. How well do you know yourself? Chances are you'll tell me you know yourself very well. All of us like to believe this. We feel like we know ourselves better than anyone else does. Every day we make choices based on this knowledge we have of ourselves. We decide how to spend our money, who to vote for, where to go for dinner, based on what we know of our predilections and preferences. But our knowledge of ourselves is not always accurate.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我有一个问题要问你。你对自己了解多少？你很可能会告诉我，你非常了解自己。我们所有人都喜欢这样认为。我们觉得比起其他人，我们更了解自己。每天，我们都基于这种对自我的认知来做出选择。我们根据自己已知的偏好和喜好，决定如何花钱、投票给谁、去哪里吃晚餐。但我们对自己的了解并不总是准确的。
A host of biases and self-deceptions keep us from seeing ourselves clearly. When you ask people how smart they are, or how ethical they are, or how good-looking they are for example, majority say they are above average, which of course is mathematically impossible. But it isn't just about vanity. How many times have you gone to a restaurant you've been to before and ordered the same dish you ordered last time only to remember after you started eating it that you didn't like it the last time. Or think about your last romantic entanglement that ended in disaster. By the time it ended, did you wonder how your past self could have gotten involved with someone so unsuitable?
大量的偏见和自我欺骗让我们无法清晰地审视自己。例如，当你问人们他们有多聪明、多有道德或多好看时，大多数人会说他们高于平均水平，这在数学上显然是不可能的。但这不仅仅关乎虚荣心。你曾有多少次去过一家以前去过的餐厅，点了上次点过的同一道菜，结果吃了一口才想起上次你并不喜欢它。或者想想你上一段以灾难告终的恋情。当它结束时，你是否想过，过去的自己怎么会和如此不合适的人在一起？
Over the last few decades, researchers in a variety of disciplines have discovered there is a much better way to understand people than to ask them questions. When you ask people what books they like to read, people will tell you about the novels and biographies they think they ought to like. If you ask them what movies they want to watch, they will tell you about the movies they aspirationally want to watch. But if instead you look at the books that people actually read, or the movies they actually watch, it usually paints a different picture of their preferences. This week on Hidden Brain, how understanding what we do, instead of listening to what we say can help us make better financial choices, improve our physical and mental health
在过去的几十年里，各个学科的研究人员发现，了解一个人有一种比直接问他们问题更好的方法。当你问人们喜欢读什么书时，他们会告诉你他们认为自己“应该”喜欢的那些小说和传记。如果你问他们想看什么电影，他们会告诉你那些他们“渴望”去看的电影。但如果你观察人们实际阅读的书籍或实际观看的电影，通常会呈现出他们偏好的不同面貌。本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将探讨如何通过观察我们的行为，而不是听我们说了什么，来帮助我们做出更好的财务选择，改善我们的身心健康，
and maybe even bridge our political divides. Philosophers tell us the highest wisdom is to know ourselves. They say this precisely because knowing ourselves is difficult, not easy. It requires self-reflection, self-awareness, and a healthy dose of humility. At Columbia University, psychologist Sandra Matz studies how one aspect of our behavior can reveal surprising truths about who we are. Sandra Matz, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
甚至可能弥合我们的政治分歧。哲学家告诉我们，最高的智慧是认识你自己。他们之所以这样说，恰恰是因为认识自己很难，并不容易。这需要自我反思、自我意识和适度的谦逊。在哥伦比亚大学，心理学家桑德拉·马茨研究了我们行为的一个方面如何揭示关于我们是谁的惊人真相。桑德拉·马茨，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢你的邀请。
Sandra, you grew up in a small village in Germany which had two restaurants and no shops. Can you paint me a picture of the place where you grew up? Yes, happily. It's a village of 500 people in the very southwest corner of Germany. As you said, it has two restaurants, no shops, one church, I should say. It's very important to the people living there. And it was really like a small community. So one day I understand that your doorbell rang and it was a neighbor reporting a missing rabbit? Yeah, I must have been I think eight, nine
桑德拉，你在德国的一个小村庄长大，那里只有两家餐馆，没有商店。你能为我描绘一下你成长的地方吗？好的，我很乐意。那是一个位于德国最西南角、只有500人的村庄。正如你所说，它有两家餐馆，没有商店，我应该说，还有一座教堂。这对住在那里的人来说非常重要。它真的就像一个小社区。那么，我听说有一天你的门铃响了，是一个邻居来报告一只兔子丢了？是的，我想我当时大概八、九岁，
years old and I had this pet rabbit or bunny called Schnuful and he was living outside. We had built him this house outside, my dad and I, and one day the neighbor comes and says that they found him in their garden feasting on their vegetables and salad. And so they tried to catch him already, but unsuccessfully. And so they were trying to get more manpower. So now my entire family is up and their entire family is up. We're trying to get him. And I don't know if you've ever had a bunny or let alone try to catch one. They're really fast. So they zigzag around and it's almost impossible to catch them. So we must've looked like clowns running around.
我有一只叫Schnuful的宠物兔，它住在外面。我和我爸爸在外面给它搭了个窝。有一天，邻居跑来说他们在花园里发现它正在大快朵颐他们的蔬菜和沙拉。他们已经试着去抓它，但没成功。于是他们想找更多人手。现在我们全家出动，他们全家也出动了。我们都在试图抓住它。我不知道你有没有养过兔子，更不用说去抓一只了。它们真的很快。它们会曲折地跑来跑去，几乎不可能抓到。所以我们当时看起来一定像是在跑来跑去的小丑。
And that certainly didn't go unnoticed. So very soon into our hunt, I think the entire street really was involved. So we had someone was managing the traffic because the bunny would just kind of run from one side of the street to the next. And then we had like, it really felt like a command center. So people were strategizing about whether we should set up a trap for the rabbit or whether we should just try to lure him in with a treat. Eventually we caught him. But it was certainly an adventure for the entire neighborhood. How was the rabbit eventually recaptured? Was it a dramatic moment?
这当然引起了注意。所以很快，在我们的搜捕行动开始后，我想整条街的人都参与进来了。有人在指挥交通，因为兔子会从街道的一边跑到另一边。我们甚至感觉像有一个指挥中心。人们在商量是应该给兔子设个陷阱，还是应该用食物引诱它。最终我们抓住了它。但这对于整个社区来说确实是一次冒险。那只兔子最终是怎么被抓回来的？那是一个戏剧性的时刻吗？
It was a dramatic moment. So it was actually one of my neighbors who leaped and caught him on the on the back leg. And I just remembered that the rabbit screaming I never I didn't even know that rabbits could scream that loudly. And then all the kids were crying because the rabbit was screaming. And so I think the adults were just happy that we got him. But it was certainly a dramatic capture. I'm getting a sense that this was a village where everyone knew everyone's business.
那确实是一个戏剧性的时刻。其实是我的一位邻居扑上去抓住了它的后腿。我只记得兔子在尖叫，我甚至不知道兔子能叫得那么大声。所有的孩子都哭了，因为兔子在尖叫。我想大人们只是很高兴我们抓住了它。但这确实是一次戏剧性的抓捕。我感觉到这是一个每个人都知道每个人私事的村庄。
Very much so, very much so. So when you were 15 Sandra, you loved riding around the village with your boyfriend on a motorcycle. What was this bike like and where would you go? Yeah, so it was, I still remember it, it was like a red Suzuki Bandit and it was, I thought it was beautiful. I was 15, he was a bit older and we would just take it from one village to the next through the hills and up and down the serpentines. And I loved riding it but I was usually in the back. So at some point I think I got really tired of being in the back and I knew that I would have to wait for another three years because in Germany you get your license at 18 at the earliest. So I kind of tried to sneakily convince him to let me just try. I found this abandoned airfield and I just told him let me just kind of ride for a few meters
确实如此，非常如此。那么桑德拉，当你15岁时，你喜欢和男朋友骑摩托车在村子里转悠。那辆摩托车是什么样的？你们会去哪里？是的，我还记得，那是一辆红色的铃木Bandit，我觉得它很漂亮。我当时15岁，他比我大一点。我们会骑着它穿过山丘，在蜿蜒的道路上从一个村庄到另一个村庄。我喜欢骑车，但我通常坐在后面。所以后来我想我真的厌倦了坐在后面，而且我知道我还要再等三年，因为在德国，你最早要到18岁才能拿到驾照。所以我试着偷偷说服他让我试一试。我找到了一个废弃的机场，告诉他让我骑几米，
you're going to get the bike back it's all going to be good. He was a bit skeptical at first but then agreed to let me try. So we start and I don't know exactly what happened. I think we must have kind of moved to the grass and I was trying to pull the bike back, but suddenly I think I just turn on the gas and the bike rises. My boyfriend falls off the back and I just speed away. So I have no idea what I'm doing. Now suddenly I'm alone on the bike without any sense of like how to handle it.
你会拿回车的，一切都会好的。他起初有点怀疑，但后来同意让我试试。我们开始骑了，我不太清楚到底发生了什么。我想我们一定是骑到了草地上，我试图把车拉回来，但突然间我好像加了油门，车子翘了起来。我男朋友从后面摔了下去，而我直接加速冲了出去。我根本不知道自己在做什么。现在我突然独自骑在车上，完全不知道该怎么控制它。
I'm trying kind of going left and right and left and right. And at some point I essentially crash on the side. Luckily it was still going slowly but there was my first experience riding the bike myself. Sandra and her boyfriend weren't hurt but Sandra had to spend a year's worth of tutoring money to get the bike repaired. But in a way that wasn't the worst part. For me, the worst part was that, I would say the minute we dropped the bike at the shop, everybody knew. So people knew about me asking my boyfriend
我试图左右摇晃，最后我基本上侧翻摔倒了。幸运的是，当时车速还很慢，但那是我第一次自己骑车的经历。桑德拉和她的男朋友没有受伤，但桑德拉不得不花掉一年的补习费来修理这辆车。但在某种程度上，这还不是最糟糕的部分。对我来说，最糟糕的是，我想我们把车送到修理店的那一分钟，所有人都知道了。人们知道我请求男朋友
to drive the bike, me crashing the bike, which was even worse. Otherwise it could have potentially been a cool story, but certainly wasn't. So everybody knew what had happened and just I was punished for weeks after with people asking me about it. When you say you were punished, how so?
让我骑车，还知道我把车撞坏了，这更糟糕。否则这可能是一个很酷的故事，但显然不是。所以每个人都知道发生了什么，之后我被惩罚了好几周，人们不停地问我这件事。当你说是被惩罚时，是指什么？
What was the reaction of your neighbors and friends? Very, I mean, very different. So some neighbors actually just went back to their own childhood and they were like, oh, that's like such a brave and fun thing to do. And they just recounted their own childhood offenses. Others were like, how could you ever do this? We thought that you were actually one of the good kids on the block. So, but it was just one conversation after the other that was all about me crashing the bike. Was there anything good that came from all
你的邻居和朋友们有什么反应？非常，我是说，非常不同。有些邻居实际上回想起了他们自己的童年，他们说，哦，那是一件多么勇敢和有趣的事情啊。他们讲述了他们自己童年时的“罪行”。其他人则说，你怎么能做这种事？我们还以为你是街区里的好孩子呢。所以，那是一次又一次关于我撞车的话题。从所有这些
the surveillance, Sandra? Certainly. I mean, I think that maybe not the bike surveillance. I think this one was a hard one. But generally speaking, the fact that my neighbors knew everything about my business also meant that there was a community that I felt safe in. So it was a community of people who knew me, who tried to help when I was looking for advice. And I've never quite experienced anything like it ever since. Was there a time when you in fact got very useful advice from these people because in fact they knew you quite well? I think so. I mean some of them were just trying to interfere with my life but some of the advice I got was incredibly helpful. So one of the ones that I still remember is that when I was finishing high school, I was thinking about doing a gap year.
监视中，有什么好的结果吗，桑德拉？当然。我是说，也许不是关于撞车的监视。我觉得那次很难受。但总的来说，邻居们了解我的一切，也意味着我生活在一个让我感到安全的社区里。这是一个了解我的人组成的社区，当我寻求建议时，他们会试图提供帮助。从那以后，我再也没有体验过类似的感觉。有没有什么时候你确实从这些人那里得到了非常有用的建议，因为他们确实很了解你？我想是的。我是说，他们中有些人只是想干涉我的生活，但有些建议确实非常有帮助。我记得其中一个建议是，当我高中毕业时，我在考虑是否要间隔年（gap year）。
It sounded like a dream to me. I was like, well, you can travel the world. You can take a year off. Don't rush into university. But I remember being quite torn because not many of my friends were considering it. And I was very ambitious, I would say, at the time. So I was like, well, maybe it's just a waste of my time to spend a year traveling. I could start university, get a job. And luckily, a lot of my neighbors told me like, look, you seem like someone who's been
这对我来说听起来像个梦想。我想，好吧，你可以环游世界。你可以休息一年。不要急着上大学。但我记得我很纠结，因为我的朋友们没几个考虑这个。而且我当时非常雄心勃勃。所以我心想，花一年时间去旅行可能只是浪费时间。我可以开始上大学，找份工作。幸运的是，我的很多邻居告诉我，看，你看起来一直渴望离开这个村庄去看看外面的世界。为什么不去做呢？你以后可以工作很多很多年，你真的应该考虑一下。他们甚至帮我找了一份工作来攒钱。所以我认为那是让我感到非常被支持的时刻之一。在某种程度上，听起来他们了解你甚至比你自己还了解你。
always craving to leave this village to see some of the world. Why don't you do it? Like, you can work for many, many years after, you should really consider it. They helped me even find a job to scrape together the money. So I think that was one of the times that I felt very much supported. And in some ways it sounds like they knew you almost better than you knew yourself.
在某些方面，我会说是的，因为我认为那是一个稍微不那么偏见、也许也不那么自我批判的“我”。桑德拉在村子里被爱管闲事的邻居包围的经历，是大多数人类在大部分历史中生活的方式。我们通常生活在小群体中，群体中的人了解关于我们的一切。今天，我们许多人生活在一种不同的村庄里。这是一个全球村，匿名实体而不是我们真正的邻居在注视着我们。并不是所有人都怀着我们最好的
In some ways I would say so, because I think it was a slightly less biased and maybe self-critical version of myself. Sandra's experience with the nosy neighbors in her village is what life has been like for most humans through most of human history. We've typically lived in small groups and people in those groups have known everything there is to know about us. Today many of us live in a different kind of village. It's a global village where anonymous entities, rather than our actual neighbors, have eyes on us. Not all of them have our best
利益。稍后回来，我们将探讨我们的数字足迹揭示了关于我们的什么信息，以及这些信息如何被用来帮助我们或伤害我们。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。每天，当我们生活时，我们都在向世界展示自己的方方面面。如果你经常光顾当地的一家面包店，那可能是因为你喜欢糕点和烘焙食品。如果你花时间在公园里，那是因为你重视自然和休闲。一个除了上班几乎不出门的人可能比较内向。在哥伦比亚大学，计算社会科学家桑德拉·马茨
interests at heart. When we come back, what our digital footprints reveal about us and how this information can be used both to help us and to harm us. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Every day, as we go about our lives, we reveal aspects of ourselves to the world. If you visit a local bakery a lot, it's probably because you like pastries and baked goods. If you spend time in parks, it's because you value nature and recreation. Someone who rarely ventures outside their home except to go to work might be introverted. At Columbia University, computational social scientist Sandra Matz
研究了我们所说和所做的事情如何揭示我们的思想、偏好和个性。桑德拉，我想谈谈我们在生活中无意中留下的线索。让我们从物理世界开始。多年前，你正在约会，进展顺利，最后你去了约会对象的公寓。告诉我你一进那个地方做了什么。是的，那是个有趣的故事，因为我记得走进公寓时，你知道你第一次见到
studies how the things we say and do reveal things about our thoughts, preferences, and personalities. Sandra, I want to talk about the clues we unintentionally leave behind us as we go about our lives. Let's start in the physical world. Many years ago you were on a date and things were going well and you ended up at your date's apartment. Tell me what you did as soon as you got to this place. Yeah, that's a funny story because I remember entering the apartment and you know you meet
某人，你根本不知道他们是谁。我走进公寓，它一尘不染。首先，它有一个我非常喜欢的巨大书库，里面有希伯来语、英语和法语的书籍，所以我心想，天哪，这是个书呆子，我爱死这一点了。我走到厨房，它闪闪发光，这我可不能说我自己的厨房也是这样。所以我印象非常深刻，因为一切都井井有条。比如刀具摆放得非常完美。我拿了一些杯子，它们完美无瑕。没有任何痕迹，没有任何水渍。
someone for the first time, you have no idea who they are. And I entered the apartment and you know you meet someone for the first time you have no idea who they are and I entered the apartment and it's pristine. It's first of all has this huge library which I loved and had books in in Hebrew and English and French and so it's like oh man this is a bookworm I love it already and walk to the kitchen it It's sparkling clean, which I cannot say of my own kitchen. So I was highly impressed in the sense that like everything had its place. Like the knives were perfectly organized. I got some glasses for us and they were perfect. Like, no, no marks any, no water marks anywhere.
我开始在脑海中构建这个住在他公寓里的人——也就是我当时约会的那个男人——他是一个什么样的人。他感觉就像是一个好奇、爱书的人，有着近乎强迫症般的秩序感。所以你当时并没有戴着帽子，也没有拿着放大镜，但我觉得你在那间公寓里的行为隐约有种夏洛克·福尔摩斯的味道。确实感觉像夏洛克·福尔摩斯，我想我们一直在这样做，对吧？
And I just kind of started building this image of like who the person living in his apartment, the guy I was dating at the time, who he was. And it just felt like he was this curious book-loving person with almost like an OCD sense of order. So you weren't wearing, you know, a hat and carrying around a magnifying glass, but it feels vaguely Sherlock Holmes-ian to me, what you were doing in that apartment. It does feel like Sherlock Holmes and I think we do this
我们遇到新的人，寻找关于那个人是谁的线索，可能是他们的公寓，可能是他们的穿着，可能是他们说的话。我们实际上是在试图把拼图碎片拼凑在一起。那次约会进展如何？嗯，结果非常好。他现在是我的丈夫，我们有一个10个月大的孩子。我很好奇，你对你丈夫的第一印象，当你约会时，后来证明准确吗，桑德拉？非常准确。所以我想，我会说他可能是我认识的最具好奇心的人。他喜欢播客，喜欢阅读，喜欢学习关于世界的一切。
all the time, right? We meet someone new, we look for clues of who that person is, could be their apartment, could be what they're wearing, could be what they're saying. It's really, we're kind of trying to piece the puzzle pieces together in a way. How did things go with this date? Well, it worked out really nicely. He's now my husband and we have a 10 month old. I'm wondering whether your impressions of your husband, your first impressions of him when you were dating, did they turn out to be accurate, Sandra? Very accurate. So I think he, I would say he's probably the most curious person I know. He loves podcasts, loves reading, loves to learn everything about the world.
而且我必须说，他确实有点强迫症。是好的那种。心理学家萨姆·高斯林（Sam Gosling）已经证明，当有机会在办公室或卧室里“窥探”时，人们在判断陌生人的个性方面实际上非常准确。告诉我这项工作，桑德拉。是的，这实际上是启发了我所有数字空间研究的工作。萨姆·高斯林是第一批试图弄清楚陌生人在查看我们的卧室和办公室时，判断我们个性有多准确的人之一。
And he also, I have to say, is a little bit OCD. In a good way. So the psychologist Sam Gosling has shown that people in fact are remarkably accurate at judging the personality of strangers when given the chance to snoop around their offices or bedrooms. Tell me about this work, Sandra. Yeah, so this is actually work that inspired all of my research in the digital space. So Sam Gosling was one of the first people to try and figure out like how good are strangers at judging our personality if they just take a look at our bedrooms and our offices and
他区分了你在某人的办公室或卧室里可以找到的两种线索。他说，嗯，你在某人的办公室或卧室里找到的一些线索是他们有意留下的“身份声明”，对吧？我们贴上一张Lady Gaga的海报，因为那是我们想向世界发出的信号，表明我们喜欢音乐，这就是我们喜欢的音乐类型。但还有所有这些我们并没有真正考虑过的其他线索，对吧？比如袜子乱放，床没铺。这和我丈夫正好相反。这只是稍微有点乱。
And he distinguished between these two types of cues that you can find So he said well some of the cues that you find in someone's office or bedroom are the intentional identity claims that we that we put There right so we put up a poster of Lady Gaga because that's the signal that we want to send to the world of well We're into music and this is the type of music that we like. But then there's also all of these other cues that we don't really think about, right? So the socks are disorganized, the bed isn't made. It's the opposite of my husband. It's just like probably a little bit more disorganized.
萨姆·高斯林真正展示的是，如果你把所有这些东西结合起来，你就能很好地了解住在这里的人是谁。所以你说，你在村子里的经历，或者你访问约会对象住所时的行为，与我们在网上发生的事情之间存在相似之处。就好像你村里的邻居现在可以访问你的Facebook消息和信用卡消费记录了？
So what Sam Gosling really showed is that if you combine all of these things, you get a pretty good sense of who the person living in these places is. So you say there are parallels between what happened in your village or your behavior when you visited your date's place and what happens to us online. It's as if your village neighbors now have access to your Facebook messages and credit card purchases?
是的，在某种程度上，对吧？我可以看看你的办公室或卧室，或者我可以看看我的邻居在做什么。但在某种层面上，我认为我们现在都生活在这个我称之为“数字村庄”的地方。所以我们一直在留下这些痕迹，这些数字痕迹。这可能是任何东西，从你在社交媒体上发布的内容——也就是相对明确的身份声明——到你的智能手机捕获的数据，比如GPS记录、你去过哪里、你的信用卡、你买了什么。
Yeah, so in a way, right, so I could take a look at your office or your bedroom or I could see what my neighbors are doing. But on some level, I think we all now live in this, what I think of as a digital village. And so we all leave these traces, these digital traces all the time. That could be anything from the stuff that you post on social media. So again, relatively explicit identity claims to the data that is captured by your smartphone, so GPS records, where do you go, your credit card, what do you buy.
就像我们可以从某人的卧室拼凑出信息一样，我们也可以在某人的数字空间里这样做。你说只需要极少的信息就能得到关于人们极其详细的画像，即使是在像纽约这样的大城市。现在纽约每天发生数百万笔交易。找到任何一个人看起来就像大海捞针。
In the same way that we could put the pieces together from someone's bedroom, we can also do that in someone's digital space. You say it takes shockingly little information to get an extremely granular picture about people, even in a big town like New York City. Now there are millions of transactions that take place every day in New York. Finding any one person might seem like you're looking for a needle in a haystack.
是的，这实际上是我最喜欢的来自麻省理工学院的研究之一。他们展示的是，根据你的消费记录或GPS记录来识别某人非常容易。你可以想象，正如你所说，纽约有数百万人。即使我们获得了他们所有的信用卡消费记录，并将其匿名化，没有名字，没有个人标识符，也很容易对数据进行反向工程。你可以想象，假设你
Yeah, it's actually one of my favorite studies that was coming out of MIT. And what they showed is that it's very easy to identify someone based on your spending records or your GPS records. So you can imagine, as you said, like there's millions of people in New York. And even if we say got access to all of their credit card spending, anonymize it so we don't have names, we don't have any personal identifiers, it's very easy to reverse engineer data. You can imagine that let's say you
早上7点20分在纽约72街的星巴克买了一杯抹茶拿铁。然后你在某个地方吃午饭，晚上可能坐出租车去市中心。在某个时刻，只有极少数人拥有完全相同的特征。所以你可以把它看作是由你的数据组成的指纹。我想谈谈你和其他人发现的数字足迹如何揭示我们生活中深刻真相的一些方式。2019年，你进行了一项研究，根据一个极其不可能的来源预测了人们的收入。告诉我你发现了什么，桑德拉。是的，这在某种程度上是整个领域中最有趣的部分。
You can imagine that, let's say, you go and get a matcha latte at Starbucks on 72nd Street in New York at 720 a.m. Then you have lunch in a certain place and maybe you take a cab downtown at night. There's at some point only so many people who have exactly that same signature. So you can almost think of it as a fingerprint that is made up of your data. as a fingerprint that is made up of your data. I want to talk about some of the ways you and others have found that our digital footprints can reveal deep truths about our lives. In 2019, you ran a study that predicted people's income based on an extremely unlikely source. Tell me what you found, Sandra. Yeah, so that's in a way the most interesting part of this entire field of
研究是这样的，是的，我们可以识别你这个人，我们可以根据你的数据知道那是尚卡尔。但对我来说，更有趣的部分实际上是我们能够深入研究你的心理，我们可以看看你的内心在想什么。我们试图预测某人收入的研究，本质上是依赖于他们的Facebook数据。那么人们在社交媒体上谈论和发布的内容是什么？我认为我们发现了一些非常有趣，有时
research is like, yeah, we can identify you as a person, we can know that it's shrunk or based on your data. But for me, the more interesting part is actually that we can dive into your psychology so we can take a look at what's going on inside your mind. And so the study that we did when we tried to predict someone's income was essentially relying on their Facebook data. So so the study that we did when we tried to predict someone's income was essentially relying on their Facebook data. So what is it that people talk about and post on social media? And I think there were some really interesting, sometimes
相当令人不安的真相。但总的来说，结论是，仅仅通过观察你在Facebook上谈论的内容，我们就能很好地了解你的社会经济地位。我很困惑这是怎么做到的。我是说，我发布关于我看过的电影或我度过的假期，你怎么能根据这些帖子判断我的收入呢，桑德拉？是的。
quite uncomfortable truth that we discovered. But overall, the bottom line was that just by looking at what you talk about on Facebook, we can have a pretty good sense of your socioeconomic status. I'm puzzled by how that would be the case. I mean, what does my posting about a movie that I've watched or a vacation that I've taken, how do you tell what my income is based on those postings, Sandra? Yeah.
当你开始打开这个“黑匣子”时，你会发现其中一些线索相对明显。你可以想象，有钱人谈论他们将要去的假期，谈论昂贵的奢侈品牌，比那些为生计挣扎的人要多得多。但还有一些更微妙的线索，我觉得更有趣，
So when you start opening the black box, what you see is some of them are like, some of the cues are relatively obvious. So you can imagine that people with a lot of money, they talk about the vacations that they're gonna take, they talk about expensive luxury brands, a lot more often than people who are struggling to make ends meet. But there's also these more subtle cues that I found even more interesting,
例如，低收入人群谈论自己更多，谈论现在更多，而高收入人群则不然。起初，你可能会想，为什么会这样？我认为这只是因为，如果你正在为赚足够的钱来维持生计而挣扎，那么除了如何应对当下，真的很难去想其他任何事情。所以这些都是关于我们内心正在发生什么的“小秘密”，我们可以在数据中揭示出来。令人着迷的是，我们大多数人并没有在想，我的帖子是在描述当下发生的事情，还是关于未来的事情，
which is for example, that lower income people, they talk more about themselves and they talk more about the present than higher income people. And in the beginning, you might be wondering, like, why might this be the case? And I think it's just that it's really damn hard to think of anything else other than how you make the present work if you're struggling to make enough money
例如，但这种差异实际上可以揭示关于我们的一些信息。是的，我认为这就是“身份声明”和“行为残留”之间的区别，我觉得这非常有趣，对吧？所以，你可能会发布关于这个豪华假期的内容，这是向世界发出的一个非常明确的信号，表明你过得很开心，而且你负担得起这次旅行。但随后所有这些更微妙的线索，比如你谈论自己，你更关注当下，这肯定是我们不一定打算揭示的东西。
to put food on the table. So those are all these little, I think, like secrets about what's going on inside our mind that we can uncover in the data. What's fascinating about that, of course, is that most of us are not thinking, are my posts describing something that's happening in the present or something that is about the future,
你刚才用了一个有趣的短语，“行为残留”。你指的是什么，桑德拉？是的，“行为残留”是我们随着生活进行而无意中留下的所有痕迹。在离线环境中，你可以想象，那就像垃圾桶溢出，袜子没整理，床没铺。而在数字世界中，它是我们不假思索地产生的所有痕迹。例如，你的智能手机几乎24小时全天候捕获你的GPS记录。你并不是有意坐下来去创建一个关于你去过哪里、在那里做了什么的记录。
for example, but that difference, in fact, can reveal something about us. Yeah, and I think that's the distinction between identity claims and behavioral residue that I think is so interesting, right? So again you might post about this luxury vacation and it's a very clear signal to the world that you're having a great time and you can afford going on this vacation. But then all of these more subtle ones where you talk about yourself, you're more focused on the present, that's certainly something that we don't necessarily intend to reveal.
但这些痕迹依然存在。让我们看看这些行为残留如何告诉我们关于我们生活以及他人生活的重要信息。研究人员Youyou Wu曾经研究过你能从一个人的Facebook点赞中了解到什么。是的，那真的非常……Youyou Wu的研究，我会说是该领域具有里程碑意义的研究之一，因为它展示了基于相对较少的数据，我们对某人心理的预测到底有多准确。她研究了人们关注的Facebook页面。比如CNN有一个Facebook页面，你可以点赞。她展示的是，
You used an interesting phrase just now, behavioral residue. What do you mean by that, Sandra? Yeah, so behavioral residue are all of the traces that we essentially inadvertently leave as we go about our life. In the offline context, you could imagine, again, that's like the bin overflowing, that's your socks not beingflowing, that's your socks not being organized, that's the bed not being made. And in the digital world, it's all of the traces that we generate without really thinking about it. So that could be your smartphone, for example, captures your GPS records pretty much continuously, 24-7. And you're not intentionally sitting down to create a record of where you went and what you did there.
仅仅通过观察你的Facebook页面，算法实际上比我们的同事、朋友、家人更能准确地预测你的个性。请注意，这些人可是非常了解你的人，对吧？那是你的父母、兄弟姐妹、孩子。他们和你在一起度过了大量时间。这比你的另一半的判断和预测稍微差一点。现在，这是一项2015年的研究。它仅基于Facebook，所以你可以想象，如果我们能访问你所有的
But still, those traces exist. Let's look at some of the ways in which these behavioral residues can tell us important things about our lives and the lives of other people. The researcher Youyou Wu once looked at what you could learn about a person from their Facebook likes. Yeah, that was really, so the research by Youyu Wu, I would say, was one of the pivotal studies in this field, because it showed just how accurate the predictions that we can make about someone's psychology really are based on relatively little data. So she was studying the Facebook pages that people follow. So let's say CNN has a Facebook page, you can like it. And what she showed is
数字痕迹并应用更复杂的机器学习，我们可能甚至能超过你的另一半。所以研究发现，在观察某人Facebook个人资料的仅仅10个点赞后，该模型就能比他们的同事更好地判断用户的个性。在65个点赞后，它比某人的朋友更了解用户。在120个点赞后，比家人更了解。我是说，这太惊人了，桑德拉。是的，我认为让我感到惊奇的是，而且我认为这一点很重要，
that just by looking at your Facebook pages, an algorithm can actually predict your personality more accurately than our co-workers could, than our friends could, than our family members could. And mind you, those are people who know you pretty well, right? Those are your parents, those are your siblings, those are your kids. They've spent a substantial amount of time with you. And it was slightly inferior to the judgments and the predictions of your significant other. Now, this was a study that was done in 2015. It was only based on Facebook, so you could imagine that if we get access to all of your
这些模型并不完美，对吧？所以我认为任何预测总会有一定的误差，我们谈论的是平均值。所以平均而言，这些模型确实非常准确，正如你刚才所说的比较。然而，我们在个人层面仍然会犯错。所以当我们进行这些比较和预测时，我想强调的一点是，
digital traces and apply slightly more sophisticated machine learning, that we could probably outperform even your significant other. So the study found that after observing just 10 likes from someone's Facebook profile, the model was able to judge a user's personality better than their work colleagues. After 65 likes, it knew users better than someone's friends. And after 120 likes, better than family members. I mean, that's astonishing, Sandra. Yeah, and I think what is astonishing to me, and I think a point that is important,
不要把它当作真理，对吧？这是一个预测，是一个概率。平均而言它非常准确，但我们在个人层面仍然会犯错。嗯，我也假设当你拥有交叉的证据线索时，比如这项研究观察的是Facebook点赞，但如果你能将其与人们的信用卡消费记录结合起来，如果你能将其与他们的Twitter动态结合起来，如果你能将其与他们对自己所说的话结合起来，
those models aren't perfect, right? So I think any prediction always has a certain amount of error, and what we're talking about are averages. So on averages, these models are really accurate, as you just said, with a comparison. However, we still make mistakes at the individual level. So one of the things when we kind of make these comparisons and predictions that I want to highlight is that
你就会逐渐生成一个越来越准确的关于这个人是谁的画像。是的，我把它看作是我们正在拼凑的一个人的拼图。你在这里得到一块碎片，那是他们的社交媒体，然后你得到另一块碎片，那是他们的信用卡消费，还有另一块碎片，那是他们的智能手机传感数据。逐渐地，你就会看到数据背后这个人的形象浮现出来。我认为关于这种结合数据源最迷人的一点是，很多人在我谈论社交媒体时总是说，这难道不是我们是谁的“精心策划的身份”吗？这只是我们想成为的样子。我们都喜欢抹茶拿铁和很棒的假期。我们从不悲伤。所以这只是我们真正自我的“理想化版本”。
don't take it as a truth, right? It's a prediction, it's a probability. It's pretty damn accurate on average, but we're still gonna make mistakes at the individual level. Hmm, I'm also assuming that when you have intersecting lines of evidence, so this study was looking at Facebook likes, but if you were able to combine that for example with people's credit card purchases, if you were able to combine that with their Twitter feeds, if you're able to combine that with what they're saying about themselves,
对于其中一些身份声明来说确实如此，对吧？社交媒体。但如果你想，假设你想假装自己比实际更井井有条、更认真，也许你可以在Facebook上这样做几周。但要在所有数据源上，并且在几个月又几个月的时间里做到这一点，真的非常非常困难。我想知道你是否能谈谈这些在某种程度上“无意识”的算法是如何描绘出一个比我们的朋友、邻居和同事更准确的我们的形象的。其中一部分原因是我们的朋友、邻居和同事
you're gradually producing a more and more accurate profile of who of who the person is. Yeah, I think of it as like this puzzle that we're putting together of a person. So you get a piece here that's their social media, and then you get another piece that's their credit card spending, and another piece that's their smartphone sensing data. And gradually you kind of see this person behind the data emerge. And what I think is fascinating about this, this combining data sources is essentially that a lot of people always say when I talk about social media that well, isn't it just like this curated identity of who we are? It's just like who we want to be. We all like matcha lattes and amazing vacations. We're never sad. And so it's just like the self-idealized version of who we really are.
在评估我们时，将他们自己的感知和偏见带入了等式中。是的。所以我认为部分原因可能是偏见，对吧？作为人类，我们受限的一点是，我们只有一小部分经验，我们对世界有自己的视角，这影响了我们对他人做出的每一个判断。现在，我们可用的数据也少得多。如果你看看我们构建的预测模型，它们观察的是数以百万计的数据点，同时整合了所有这些数据。
That's true for some of these identity claims, right? Social media. But if you wanted to, let's say you wanted to pretend that you're more organized and conscientious than you do really are, maybe you can do this on Facebook for a couple of weeks. It's really, really difficult to do this across all data sources and across like months and months and months. I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about how these sort of in some ways mindless algorithms are painting a picture of us that's more accurate than our friends and neighbors and coworkers. And some of that is because our friends and neighbors and coworkers. And some of that is because our friends and neighbors
我们根本不可能拥有数以百万计的友谊，让我们能够根据某人的行为来判断他们的个性。是的，我是说在某种程度上，这就像是“类固醇版的夏洛克·福尔摩斯”，这些机器正在做的事情，对吧？因为它们实际上获取了海量的数据，远超我们大多数人在物理世界中能够观察到的。是的，让我们想象一下，这就像是拥有百万个华生的夏洛克·福尔摩斯。所以即使是我们的搜索历史，我们在网上寻找什么，也能说明很多关于我们的信息。谈谈这个，在某种程度上，我们在网上搜索的内容可以描绘出一幅关于我们是谁的非常有力的画像。是的，所以谷歌搜索，如果你考虑一下，谷歌可能是我们拥有的最亲密的知己。我们问谷歌一些我们甚至不敢问最亲密的朋友、
and coworkers are bringing their own perceptions and their own biases to the equation as they're evaluating us. Yeah. So I think part of it might be bias, right? One of the things that we're limited by as humans is we have only a sliver of experience and we have our own perspective on the world, and that's influencing every judgment that we make about other people. Now, we also have a lot less data to work with. If you look at the predictive models that we build, they are looking at millions and millions and millions of data points, all integrating them at the same time.
伴侣的问题。所以从某种层面上讲，我们搜索的任何内容实际上揭示了我们内心正在发生的大量事情，这并不令人惊讶。这可能是任何事情，从心理健康到我们可能不想看到的关于社会的真相。所以，我的一位密友塞斯·斯蒂芬斯-大卫多维茨（Seth Stevens-Davidovitz），他所做的是观察搜索数据，也就是人们进行的所有搜索，他试图揭示我们搜索的内容与关于社会的真相之间的一些关系。所以这可能是任何事情，从
There's just no way that we have access to millions of millions of friendships that allow us to then judge someone's personality based on their behavior. Yeah, I mean in some ways this is like Sherlock Holmes on steroids is what these machines are doing, right? Because they're actually picking up huge amounts of data far more than most of us are actually able to observe in the physical world. Yeah, let's imagine it's like Sherlock Holmes with comes with a million Watsons. So even our search history, what we're looking for online, can say a lot about us. Talk about this, that in some ways what we search for online can paint a very powerful picture of who we are. Yeah, so Google searches, if you think about that, Google is probably the closest confidant that we have. We ask Google questions that we don't even dare to ask our closest friends, our
人们在搜索性相关内容时搜索什么？人们搜索堕胎的频率是否比我们在官方数据中看到的更高？人们搜索种族主义笑话的频率是否比人们在公开场合承认的更高？所以我认为谷歌确实是捕捉我们内心正在发生什么的来源，那些我们不想与任何人分享的东西。所以几年前我们邀请过塞斯·斯蒂芬斯-大卫多维茨来《Hidden Brain》。
partners. So on some level, it's not surprising that whatever we search for on Google actually reveals a lot of what's going on inside. And that could be anything from mental health to truth about society that we might not want to see. So one of a close friend Seth Stevens Davidovitz and what he did is he looked at search data so all of the searches that people make and he was trying to uncover some of the relationships between what we search for and really kind of truths about society. So that could be anything from search for and really kind of truths about society. So that could be anything from what do people search for when they search for sex? Do people look for abortions more often
他提到的其中一件事是，互联网上的种族主义搜索与人们投票给巴拉克·奥巴马的可能性之间存在负相关。所以，在2008年和2012年的总统选举中，谷歌搜索中使用种族主义术语比例较高的地方，投票给巴拉克·奥巴马的可能性就越小。是的，没错。
than we actually see in the official data? Do people search for racist jokes more often than people would admit in public? So I think Google is really the source that captures like what's going on inside our mind, stuff that we don't wanna to share with anyone else. So we had Seth Stevens-Dividovitz on Hidden Brain some years ago.
而且我认为，同样，如果你看官方民意调查，没人愿意承认这一点。所以这些是在调查数据中不一定会显示的关联，但你确实会在这些更隐蔽的线索中看到它们。在另一项研究中，桑德拉，你观察了社交媒体更新与投票之间的关系，但你观察的不是明确的数据，比如人们说他们要投票给某个特定的政治家。你观察的是什么，你发现了什么？是的，所以这是我们进行的一项研究，我们观察的是
And one of the things he mentioned was that there was this negative correlation between racist searches on the internet and the likelihood that people would vote for Barack Obama. So in both the 2008 and 2012 presidential elections, places with higher rates of Google searches using racist terms were less likely to vote for Barack Obama. Yeah, that's right.
什么在驱动民粹主义投票，我们特别感兴趣的是“情感”。所以这种负面情绪在多大程度上——不仅仅是媒体中经常谈论的那种更具攻击性的负面情绪，比如愤怒，还有更微妙的情绪，比如悲伤和抑郁——在多大程度上，这些出现在社交媒体上的情绪与人们投票给民粹主义候选人有关？所以我们研究的选举之一是英国的脱欧。所以人们投票离开欧盟，或者2016年美国总统大选。
And I think, again, if you look at the official polls, nobody wants to admit that. So those are correlations that you don't necessarily see showing up in survey data, but you do see them show up in these more hidden cues. In another study, Sandra, you looked at the relationship between social media updates and voting, but you were not looking at explicit data, like people saying they were going to vote for a particular politician. What were you looking for and what did you find? Yeah, so this was a study that we did where we looked at what's
你始终会发现，在社交媒体上出现大量这种负面情绪的地区，人们也更有可能投票给这些民粹主义候选人和事业。同样，这里有趣的是，这就像抽屉里不匹配的袜子，对吧？这不是人们认为会说明他们政治偏好的信号。如果我感到心烦意乱或悲伤，或者我的整体情绪是负面的，我不认为这会揭示我的政治偏好，但事实上它确实会。
driving populist voting and what we were particularly interested in is affect. So to what extent is this negative affect and not just like the more aggressive negative affect like anger which you oftentimes see talked about in the media but also the more subtle ones like sadness and depression. To what extent are those emotions as they show up on social media linked to people voting for populist candidates? So one of the elections that we looked into was Brexit in the UK. So people voting to leave the European Union or the 2016 US presidential election.
是的，你拥有所有这些预测模型，对吧？所以你拥有所有这些试图预测选举结果的预测模型。它们中没有一个真正考虑基于社交媒体的基调或情感效价。你知道，我想起了那项分析，发现2016年总统大选中，唐纳德·特朗普赢得了所有拥有Cracker Barrel餐厅的县中四分之三的选票，但只有
And what you find consistently is that in areas where there's a lot of this negative affect showing up on social media, people are also more likely to to vote for these populist candidates and causes. And again what's interesting here is that it's like the mismatched socks in the drawer, right? It's not a signal that people are actually thinking will say something about their political preferences. If I'm feeling upset or sad or my affect in general is negative, I don't think it's gonna reveal something about my political preferences, but in fact it does.
你始终会发现，在社交媒体上出现大量负面情绪的地区，人们也更有可能投票支持这些民粹主义候选人和事业。同样有趣的是，这就像抽屉里不匹配的袜子，对吧？这并不是人们认为会反映其政治偏好的信号。如果我感到心烦意乱或悲伤，或者我的整体情绪是负面的，我不认为这会揭示我的政治偏好，但事实上它确实会。
Yeah, and you have all of these predictive models, right? So you have all of these predictive models trying to project what is the outcome of an election. None of them really consider tone or emotional valence based on social media. You know, I'm reminded of that analysis that found in the 2016 presidential election that Donald Trump won three-quarters of all counties that had a cracker barrel restaurant but only
是的，你拥有所有这些预测模型，对吧？所以你有所有这些试图预测选举结果的预测模型。它们中没有一个真正考虑基于社交媒体的语气或情感效价。你知道，我想起了那项分析，它发现 2016 年总统大选中，唐纳德·特朗普赢得了所有拥有 Cracker Barrel 餐厅的县中的四分之三，但仅
22% of counties that had a Whole Foods store. Now most people are not thinking about politics when they're shopping for groceries or or dining out but it turns out that our shopping and dining habits can reveal powerful things about us. Yeah, so sometimes I think it's like the behaviors that you show, right? Shopping and whole foods is probably a proxy for some of the more psychological variables.
22%的县有全食超市。现在大多数人在购物或外出就餐时并不会考虑政治，但事实证明，我们的购物和餐饮习惯可以揭示关于我们自身的强大信息。是的，所以有时我认为这就像是你表现出的行为，对吧？在全食超市购物可能是一些心理变量的代理指标。
That could be anything from openness, which we know is associated with being liberal, could be associated with socioeconomic status. The same way that negative emotions, for example, is associated oftentimes with a desire for change. And in that sense, it's not necessarily surprising that those people who feel currently bad about themselves want to vote for a candidate that promises change. Most of us spend a great deal of time every day in front of various devices. We scroll and tap and like and listen.
这可能是从开放性（我们知道这与自由派倾向有关）到社会经济地位的任何东西。同样，负面情绪通常与对改变的渴望有关。从这个意义上说，那些目前对自己感觉不好的人想要投票给承诺改变的候选人，这并不令人惊讶。我们大多数人每天花大量时间在各种设备前。我们滚动、点击、点赞和收听。
We search for answers to our most personal questions and post updates to our social media feeds. When we come back, how all this data can help us improve our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. You wake up in the morning and reach for your phone. You open Instagram and leave a comment on a friend's vacation pictures. You sneeze and run a Google search about allergies.
我们搜索最私密问题的答案，并在社交媒体上发布动态。当我们回来时，我们将探讨所有这些数据如何帮助我们改善生活。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你早上醒来，伸手去拿手机。你打开Instagram，给朋友的度假照片留了言。你打了个喷嚏，然后在谷歌上搜索关于过敏的信息。
On the way to work, you buy a muffin at a local cafe using your credit card. Every day, we leave dozens of tiny traces of ourselves in the digital world. At Columbia University, Sandra Matz calls the accumulation of these traces our digital footprints. She is the author of Mind Masters, the data-driven science of predicting and changing human behavior.
在上班路上，你用信用卡在当地咖啡馆买了一个松饼。每天，我们在数字世界中留下数十个微小的痕迹。在哥伦比亚大学，桑德拉·马茨（Sandra Matz）将这些痕迹的积累称为我们的“数字足迹”。她是《思维大师：预测和改变人类行为的数据驱动科学》（Mind Masters, the data-driven science of predicting and changing human behavior）一书的作者。
Sandra, you say that the traces we leave online not only paint a picture of who we are, they show marketers and political campaigns how to influence us. Now, we've all heard a lot about the problems of digital surveillance, but fewer people know how these tools can be used for good. Let's start with the work you've done showing how psychological targeting can help people save more money. So the idea here was that if we could make saving more appealing to people,
桑德拉，你说我们在网上留下的痕迹不仅描绘了我们是谁，还向营销人员和政治竞选团队展示了如何影响我们。现在，我们都听过很多关于数字监控的问题，但很少有人知道这些工具如何能被用于善途。让我们从你所做的工作开始，看看心理定位如何帮助人们存更多的钱。所以这里的想法是，如果我们能让储蓄对人们更具吸引力，
to make it more personally relevant, could we help them put that money, the extra money to the side? So we teamed up with Save a Life, which is a fintech company in the US. They are trying to help low-income families save for a rainy day. So the people that we work with were people with very low levels of savings, so less than $100. And our goal was to get them to add an additional $100 to the savings account over the course of four weeks. So we teamed up with the creative team of Save a Life,
让它与个人更相关，我们能否帮助他们把那笔钱，那笔额外的钱存起来？所以我们与美国的一家金融科技公司Save a Life合作。他们试图帮助低收入家庭为不时之需存钱。所以我们合作的对象是储蓄水平非常低的人，也就是少于100美元的人。我们的目标是让他们在四周内额外增加100美元的储蓄。所以我们与Save a Life的创意团队合作，
and we essentially asked them, well, come up with saving messages that try to encourage, say, people who are very agreeable, so people who care about other people who care about their social relationships, and maybe tell them that if you manage to put some money to the side right now, this is a great way of making sure that your loved ones are protected. Now, if you're talking to someone who is much more competitive and critical, which is the other side of the same personality trait, maybe you want to highlight how just putting this money to the
我们基本上问他们，好吧，想出一些储蓄信息，试图鼓励那些非常随和的人，也就是那些关心他人、关心社会关系的人，也许告诉他们，如果你现在能存下一些钱，这是确保你所爱之人得到保护的好方法。现在，如果你是在和一个更具竞争力和批判性的人交谈，也就是同一人格特质的另一面，也许你想强调一下，仅仅把这笔钱存起来
side gets them ahead of the game. So we kind of came up with this different type of messaging for all of the big five personality traits. And then we just sent out the messages over the course of four weeks. And we looked at how many people eventually managed to save an additional $100. What did you find? So what we find is that essentially if we target people with the messages that were tailored to their personality, about 11% of the entire sample managed
就能让他们在竞争中领先。所以我们为“大五人格”特质中的每一种都设计了不同类型的信息。然后我们在四周内发送了这些信息。我们观察了有多少人最终成功额外存下了100美元。你发现了什么？所以我们发现，基本上如果我们用针对他们人格的信息来定位人们，整个样本中大约有11%的人成功
to put $100 to the site. Now that's certainly far from perfect, but ideally we'd want this to be closer to 100%. But if you think about it, it means that someone is doubling their savings over the course of four weeks. And what's more important is that it was also much better than the existing messaging that Save a Life had been using up to this point.
存下了100美元。这当然远非完美，理想情况下我们希望这个比例接近100%。但如果你仔细想想，这意味着有人在四周内将他们的储蓄翻了一番。更重要的是，这比Save a Life在此之前一直使用的现有信息要好得多。
So they had been trying to perfect their messaging over a couple of years, and we were still 60% better than the gold standard that they were using at the time. So just to underscore the principle here, what you're doing is you're basically saying we can tell what people's personalities are by the digital footprints they're leaving behind. And if we can tailor messages in some ways to match people's personalities, those messages are far more likely to break through. Exactly.
所以他们几年来一直在尝试完善他们的信息，而我们仍然比他们当时使用的黄金标准好60%。所以为了强调这里的原则，你基本上是在说，我们可以通过人们留下的数字足迹来判断他们的个性。如果我们能以某种方式定制信息来匹配人们的个性，这些信息就更有可能产生效果。正是如此。
And you can think of it as essentially this is what we do all the time in our offline relationships. Pretty much any type of conversation that you have is to some extent tailored. You don't talk about the same things or in the same way to a friend or to your kid or to your boss. So we're trying to replicate this at scale and just say, okay, what is it that you might care about and how can we make saving more appealing to you? Our digital footprints can also reveal insights about our mental health. You and a colleague have studied whether there's a connection between depression and a
你可以认为这基本上就是我们在现实生活中一直所做的事情。几乎你进行的任何类型的对话在某种程度上都是定制的。你和朋友、孩子或老板谈论的事情或谈话方式是不一样的。所以我们正试图在大规模上复制这一点，并说，好吧，你可能关心什么，我们怎样才能让储蓄对你更有吸引力？我们的数字足迹也可以揭示关于我们心理健康的见解。你和一位同事研究了抑郁症与
person's location data. Yeah, so this is essentially research that we did with GPS records. So again, your phone tracks your GPS records pretty much 24-7. And what we were interested in is whether we could tell whether someone might be suffering from depression or not, just based on these GPS records alone. Now if you look at the content of some of these traces that we observed, they actually make a lot of sense. So what we found, for example, is that if you don't leave your house as much anymore, as you typically did, or there's much less physical activity, you don't travel to as many
一个人的位置数据之间是否存在联系。是的，所以这基本上是我们利用GPS记录所做的研究。同样，你的手机几乎24小时全天候跟踪你的GPS记录。我们感兴趣的是，仅凭这些GPS记录，我们能否判断某人是否可能患有抑郁症。现在，如果你观察我们观察到的一些痕迹的内容，它们实际上非常有意义。例如，我们发现，如果你不再像以前那样经常出门，或者身体活动减少，你不再去那么多
places as you used to, those are all small indicators that there might be something going on. It's certainly not a diagnostic tool, but it means that maybe we could be raising a red flag and say, hey, might be nothing, but why don't you check in with some support? And I suppose, you know, there's always gonna be noise in the data, so someone may have lost their phone inside their sofa cushions,
你曾经去过的地方，这些都是可能出现问题的微小指标。这当然不是一种诊断工具，但它意味着我们或许可以发出警报，说，嘿，可能没什么，但为什么不寻求一些支持呢？我想，你知道，数据中总会有噪音，所以有人可能把手机丢在沙发垫里了，
and so the phone basically sits at home for three weeks. It doesn't mean that they are depressed and they haven't left their home in three weeks. It just means that the phone was lost. But I think what you're really saying, Sandra, is that in aggregate, this data, in fact, are telling us valuable things. And at a minimum, they're basically raising a flag
所以手机基本上在家里放了三周。这并不意味着他们抑郁了，三周没出门。这只是意味着手机丢了。但我认为你真正想说的是，桑德拉，总的来说，这些数据确实在告诉我们有价值的事情。至少，它们基本上发出了一个
that warrants further investigation. Yeah, so I don't think it's a deterministic diagnostic tool, but it could be incredibly helpful for people, for example, who know already that they're suffering from depression, right? So it's like one of these mental health challenges that just pop up time and again. And it's really difficult to find your way out of the valley. So once you enter the full-fledged depression, it's really hard to come back. And so if we can get these early indicators of, well, maybe it's nothing, but here's like a warning system
值得进一步调查的信号。是的，所以我认为它不是一种决定性的诊断工具，但它对那些已经知道自己患有抑郁症的人来说可能非常有帮助，对吧？所以这就像是那些不时出现的心理健康挑战之一。走出低谷真的很难。所以一旦你进入了完全的抑郁状态，就很难恢复了。所以如果我们能得到这些早期指标，嗯，也许没什么，但这是一个预警系统，
that might alert you to, well, again, there's, but here's like a warning system that might alert you to, well, again, there's like these changes in your behavior, you're deviating from your typical routine. Why don't you reach out to someone and see if there's something to it? I mean, this is really no different than basically saying, let me measure your resting heart rate or your cholesterol levels. And over time, if I have enough data, it might paint me a picture of saying, you know, you're heading down a bad path.
可能会提醒你，嗯，同样，这里有你行为上的变化，你偏离了典型的日常习惯。为什么不联系某人看看是怎么回事呢？我的意思是，这实际上与测量你的静息心率或胆固醇水平没有什么不同。随着时间的推移，如果我有足够的数据，它可能会为我描绘出一幅图景，说，你知道，你正在走上一条糟糕的道路。
You might want to change your lifestyle. Yeah. And you can do this in real time. And technically, what you could also do if you're really thinking about this as a support system for the person is not just alert the user, but maybe I can give you the opportunity to name two people, my loved ones, someone that you want to know that you're having a hard time, even if you're not in a position to tell them.
你可能需要改变你的生活方式。是的。而且你可以实时做到这一点。从技术上讲，如果你真的把它看作是一个人的支持系统，你还可以做的是，不仅提醒用户，也许我可以让你有机会指定两个人，我的爱人，你想让他们知道你正在经历困难，即使你无法亲自告诉他们。
So our digital footprints not only reveal things about our past, they can also predict things we might do in the future. You once tried to predict dropout rates among college students by studying their digital footprints. How did you do this, Sandra? Yeah, so this is actually one of the projects that I personally care a lot about, because there's still so many students dropping out with enormous debt that they never recover. So what we were trying to do is to see if we could predict early on, once
所以我们的数字足迹不仅揭示了我们的过去，它们还可以预测我们未来可能做的事情。你曾经试图通过研究大学生的数字足迹来预测他们的辍学率。你是怎么做到的，桑德拉？是的，这实际上是我个人非常关心的项目之一，因为仍然有太多的学生背负着他们永远无法偿还的巨额债务而辍学。所以我们试图做的是看看我们是否能尽早预测，一旦
people joined university in the first semester to do is to see if we could predict early on, once people joined university in the first semester, whether we could see if they might be struggling integrating into the system. Maybe they're not finding the information that they should be finding. Maybe they're not embedded in the cohort as much as other people.
人们在第一学期进入大学，我们是否能预测他们是否在融入系统方面遇到困难。也许他们没有找到他们应该找到的信息。也许他们不像其他人那样融入群体。
And they're somewhat on the fringes, not really connecting to the community as much. So we kind of, again, teamed up with a company called Ready Education. They had a sense of what are the activities that students attending? Are they talking to other students? Are they part of groups?
他们有点处于边缘，没有真正与社区建立联系。所以我们再次与一家名为Ready Education的公司合作。他们了解学生参加了哪些活动。他们在和其他学生交谈吗？他们是小组的一部分吗？
Are they sending messages? Are they receiving messages? So we looked at all of these data traces. And again, once you combine all of them, you actually have a relatively decent sense of whether someone might be struggling and whether they might drop out at the end of the semester. And of course, when you put it this way,
他们在发送消息吗？他们在接收消息吗？所以我们查看了所有这些数据痕迹。同样，一旦你将它们结合起来，你实际上就能相对准确地判断某人是否在挣扎，以及他们是否可能在学期末辍学。当然，当你这样说的时候，
it seems to make sense now. If I know, for example, that a student doesn't have many friends and is not exchanging messages and in fact is a little bit isolated and is not spending time hanging out with other students, it's not unreasonable now to say, maybe the student doesn't feel like he or she belongs at the university and is at higher risk of dropping out.
现在看来是有道理的。例如，如果我知道一个学生没有多少朋友，没有交换信息，实际上有点孤立，也没有花时间和其他学生在一起，现在说这个学生可能觉得他不属于这所大学，并且有更高的辍学风险，这并非不合理。
Yeah, and for me, what I love most about this is essentially it creates a path to help students and at the very bare minimum, what it allows administrators to do is identify at risk students, right? So if you see that there's some students who have a higher likelihood of dropping out, maybe you allocate more resources to helping them. Now, for me, the even more interesting part is that we also get a sense of what
是的，对我来说，我最喜欢这一点的是，它基本上创造了一条帮助学生的途径，至少，它允许管理人员做的是识别高风险学生，对吧？所以如果你看到有些学生辍学的可能性更高，也许你会分配更多的资源来帮助他们。现在，对我来说，更令人感兴趣的部分是，我们还了解了是什么
is predicting dropout for each individual student. So it could be that I, for example, when I started university as a first-generation student, my problem was that I simply didn't know when I started university as a first generation student, my problem was that I simply didn't know where all of the information was sitting. I didn't know how to get the literature. I didn't know where to search for information.
在预测每个学生的辍学情况。所以可能是，例如，当我作为第一代大学生开始上大学时，我的问题是我根本不知道当我作为第一代大学生开始上大学时，我的问题是我根本不知道所有的信息都在哪里。我不知道如何获取文献。我不知道去哪里搜索信息。
And so for me, if that was the prediction that the algorithm had made, administrators could have gone in and said, here's the information that you need. You can pop it up on my app. You can send it in my email. Just make sure that I see what I need to see. Now there could be other people who know exactly, I know that most of my friends when I started
所以对我来说，如果那是算法做出的预测，管理人员本可以介入并说，这是你需要的信息。你可以把它弹在我的应用程序上。你可以把它发到我的电子邮件里。只要确保我看到了我需要看到的东西。现在可能有其他人非常清楚，我知道我刚开始时我的大多数朋友
knew exactly what they were looking for, but some of them probably had a harder time integrating with the community and finding the friends and making these connections. So for those people, if we see that that's what's happening based on the algorithm, it's a totally different intervention, right? So then we're trying to see if we can get you involved in events more. Is there a way to ask other people to connect? So the moment that you understand
都知道他们在找什么，但他们中的一些人可能在融入社区、寻找朋友和建立这些联系方面遇到了更多困难。所以对于这些人，如果我们看到基于算法的情况就是这样，那将是一种完全不同的干预措施，对吧？所以我们试图看看是否能让你更多地参与活动。有没有办法让其他人建立联系？所以当你理解了
why someone is predicted to be a dropout, you can also adjust the approaches that you use to help them. In other words, instead of a one size fits all approach, now you can actually say the individual person gets his or her own approach. Exactly. It's the same as targeted advertising, right?
为什么某人被预测会辍学时，你也可以调整你用来帮助他们的方法。换句话说，与其采用“一刀切”的方法，现在你实际上可以说，每个人都有自己的方法。正是如此。这和定向广告是一样的，对吧？
So we kind of try and figure out what each person needs at a given point in time. Same for student drop-down. What are the digital tracking tools? Sandra, you say that these digital tracking tools are increasingly being used not just to identify health issues, but to actually intervene. How so?
所以我们试图弄清楚每个人在特定时间需要什么。学生辍学也是如此。什么是数字跟踪工具？桑德拉，你说这些数字跟踪工具越来越多地被用于不仅识别健康问题，而且实际上进行干预。怎么说？
Yeah, so there's really two things that the data has to offer. And I think of it as tracking and treating. So on some level, just all of the data that we generate says a lot about our physical activity, our physical health, but also about our mental health. Again, we talked about GPS records that say something about whether you might be suffering from depression. There's a lot that we can learn about your mental health from what you post on social media. So this is the tracking part. But then what I think is really interesting and it's currently being developed,
是的，数据确实有两个方面可以提供。我认为它是跟踪和治疗。在某种程度上，我们产生的所有数据都说明了我们的身体活动、身体健康，但也说明了我们的心理健康。同样，我们谈到了GPS记录，它们说明了你是否可能患有抑郁症。从你在社交媒体上发布的内容中，我们可以学到很多关于你心理健康的信息。这就是跟踪部分。但我认为非常有趣且目前正在开发的是，
so I think we're really early stages, is more of the treatment part. So can I use your footprints to not only surface, let's say, the most relevant interventions to you, the same way that Amazon recommends products and the same way that Netflix recommends movies, can actually an algorithm who knows you based on your data recommend the best treatment for you suffering from depression. You tell the story of a woman named Chakura Ali who was in a car accident that left her severely injured. She spiraled into depression. Tell me her story and what happened to her. Yeah, so this is a really tragic story of a woman who got into an accident, got severely injured,
所以我认为我们还处于非常早期的阶段，更多的是治疗部分。所以我能利用你的足迹不仅为你呈现最相关的干预措施吗，就像亚马逊推荐产品和Netflix推荐电影一样，一个基于你的数据了解你的算法真的能为你推荐治疗抑郁症的最佳方案吗？你讲述了一个名叫查库拉·阿里（Chakura Ali）的女人的故事，她在车祸中受了重伤。她陷入了抑郁。告诉我她的故事以及她发生了什么。是的，这是一个非常悲惨的故事，一个女人出了车祸，受了重伤，
lost the bakery that she was running, shows she was self-employed, which also meant that she couldn't afford a car anymore, couldn't really provide for her family. And you can imagine that all of this takes a pretty big toll on someone's mental health. Now, with no car, no money, there's no way that you can either
失去了她经营的面包店，她是个体经营者，这也意味着她再也买不起车了，无法真正养活她的家人。你可以想象，所有这些对一个人的心理健康造成了很大的打击。现在，没有车，没有钱，你根本无法
find a therapist, let alone drive to a therapist for like your weekly session. So what she did is she started using an app that's called Wisa, which is really trying to interact with you, give you advice, ask questions about how you're feeling, gives these little prompts and little challenges. Maybe you go out to nature and maybe you try and meditate for a little bit. And I think the way that she tells the story is that it was very weird in the beginning, talking to a bot about your mental health struggles,
找到治疗师，更不用说开车去参加每周一次的治疗课程了。所以她开始使用一个名为Wisa的应用程序，它真的试图与你互动，给你建议，询问你的感受，给出这些小提示和小挑战。也许你去大自然中走走，也许你试着冥想一会儿。我认为她讲述这个故事的方式是，一开始和一个机器人谈论你的心理健康斗争是非常奇怪的，
but at some point you adjust, right? And you get used to it. And from using it once in a while, I think she started using it multiple times a day. What was the effect of using this bot on her mental health, Sandra? So in her case, I think it significantly improved her mental health. It certainly didn't fix all of the problems, right? And just still a lot of effort that you have to put in as a human being, but it felt like there was a support system that she otherwise couldn't have afforded.
但在某个时候你会适应，对吧？你会习惯的。从偶尔使用它，我想她开始每天多次使用它。使用这个机器人对她的心理健康有什么影响，桑德拉？所以在她的案例中，我认为它显著改善了她的心理健康。它当然没有解决所有问题，对吧？作为一个人类，你仍然需要付出很多努力，但感觉就像有一个支持系统，否则她负担不起。
And again, I don't think you're necessarily suggesting that, you know, a bot is necessarily an ideal replacement for a human therapist, but you're saying in a situation like this, where in fact, you know, the person cannot afford or cannot get to a human therapist, this would be a potential solution. Yeah. So I think if you have access to a human being, blood and flesh, who can be your therapist, that's probably preferable. However, there's this huge gap in terms of how many therapists there are and how many
同样，我不认为你一定是在暗示，你知道，机器人一定是人类治疗师的理想替代品，但你是在说，在这样的情况下，事实上，你知道，这个人负担不起或无法找到人类治疗师，这将是一个潜在的解决方案。是的。所以我认为如果你能接触到有血有肉的人类，他们可以成为你的治疗师，那可能更可取。然而，在有多少治疗师和有多少
people are seeking therapy. So then there is a really huge need for people to get at least some support in cases where they can't get hold of a human being. Many people are worried that digital tracking has increased polarization. The moment you click on one video with a political theme, the algorithms quickly paint a picture of you as liberal or conservative and start feeding you more and more of the same content. In other words, digital tracking and psychological targeting can quickly leave you inside an echo chamber. You say it's at least theoretically possible
人寻求治疗之间存在巨大的差距。因此，在人们无法接触到人类的情况下，确实有非常巨大的需求来获得至少一些支持。许多人担心数字跟踪加剧了极化。当你点击一个带有政治主题的视频时，算法会迅速将你描绘成自由派或保守派，并开始向你推送越来越多相同的内容。换句话说，数字跟踪和心理定位可以迅速将你困在回声室里。你说这至少在理论上是可能的
to use these same tools to reduce polarization? Oh yeah, that's it's one of my favorite applications. But the idea here is that it actually offers this what I think of as like a magical echo chamber swap machine. Because it's really difficult for me to figure out, well, what is the reality of, let's say, a 50-year-old guy in the middle of Ohio? I just don't have direct access.
利用这些相同的工具来减少极化？哦，是的，这是我最喜欢的应用之一。但这里的想法是，它实际上提供了我所认为的“神奇回声室交换机”。因为我很难弄清楚，嗯，俄亥俄州中部一个50岁男人的现实是什么？我只是没有直接接触的机会。
It's really difficult for me to step into their shoes and see what does their day-to-day look like. Same for, let's say, a single mom in the suburbs of Chicago. But Google knows, right? Google knows exactly what those people see every day when they search for something specific. Facebook knows exactly what their newsfeed looks like every day. So instead of keeping me in my own echo chamber and just feeding more of the stuff that I already know, they could actually allow me to hop into the echo chambers of other people.
我很难设身处地地去看看他们的日常生活是什么样的。芝加哥郊区的一位单身母亲也是如此。但谷歌知道，对吧？谷歌确切地知道这些人每天搜索特定内容时看到了什么。Facebook确切地知道他们的动态消息每天看起来是什么样的。所以，与其把我关在自己的回声室里，只喂给我更多我已经知道的东西，他们实际上可以让我跳进其他人的回声室。
In other words, if I know that you are basically self-selecting into one echo chamber, you're saying what if these platforms in some ways can encourage us to basically visit other echo chambers and in some ways broaden our worldviews? Yeah, so it could be an explorer mode, right? And the explorer mode at the very basic level could be, well, just do an echo chamber swap with someone.
换句话说，如果我知道你基本上是在自我选择进入一个回声室，你是说如果这些平台在某种程度上能鼓励我们基本上访问其他回声室，并在某种程度上拓宽我们的世界观会怎样？是的，所以它可以是一个“探索模式”，对吧？在最基本的层面上，探索模式可以是，嗯，只是和某人进行一次回声室交换。
So maybe someone is happy to let you access their Facebook feed and you give them access to yours. At the more sophisticated level, they could build an engine that allows you to specify exactly which echo chamber you want to hop into, right? I can say, here's the demographics of the person, here's the preferences, here's the age, gender, whatever you want to see. And then you can hop into the echo chamber. Now, I don't think we're going to use it all too often. The argument by
所以也许有人很乐意让你访问他们的Facebook动态，而你让他们访问你的。在更复杂的层面上，他们可以构建一个引擎，让你精确指定你想跳进哪个回声室，对吧？我可以指定，这是这个人的统计数据，这是偏好，这是年龄、性别，任何你想看的东西。然后你就可以跳进那个回声室。现在，我不认为我们会太频繁地使用它。谷歌的论点是
Google is nobody would use it because it's so comfortable in our own echo chamber. And I think that is largely true. Most of the time, we probably love to not have to go to page two of Google because we find what we want to see on page one, but I at least want to have the option, see well, what is the search result for like immigration that someone with a totally different political ideology than me in a totally different part of the country sees that I would never otherwise get to see?
没有人会使用它，因为在自己的回声室里太舒服了。我认为这在很大程度上是正确的。大多数时候，我们可能喜欢不必去谷歌的第二页，因为我们在第一页找到了我们想看的东西，但我至少想有这个选择，看看嗯，对于像移民这样的搜索结果，一个在国家完全不同地区、政治意识形态与我完全不同的人看到了什么，而我永远无法看到？
When I'm thinking about the concerns that major platforms might have in serving up this kind of information, I'm struck by the fact that in some ways I think, Sandra, what you're talking about is the difference between the information we want and the information that we need. So the information that I want might be information that basically confirms that my pre-existing views are correct. The information that I need might in fact tell me, hey, take a look at what's happening on the other side. I think that's absolutely true. And to, in all fairness, some of it is human nature. So the reason for why these algorithms work and the reason for why companies craft them in their effort to make profits is because we love to see stuff that we believe in anyway. It's very comforting, it's very reassuring to see stuff that is aligned with our worldview.
当我想到主要平台在提供这类信息时可能有的担忧时，我被这样一个事实所打动，即在某些方面我认为，桑德拉，你所谈论的是我们想要的信息和我们需要的信息之间的区别。所以我想要的信息可能是基本上证实我预先存在的观点是正确的信息。我需要的信息可能实际上是在告诉我，嘿，看看另一边发生了什么。我认为这绝对是真的。而且，公平地说，其中一些是人性。所以这些算法之所以有效，以及公司之所以在努力盈利的过程中精心设计它们，是因为我们喜欢看到我们无论如何都相信的东西。看到与我们的世界观一致的东西是非常令人欣慰、非常令人安心的。
So that's why I feel like this explorer mode is just one option that allows us to at least get some collective oversight. So even if we're not using it as much, it still means that we have an option to see what's happening on the other side. In our companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we look at the downsides of digital surveillance. We take a closer look at the harms of tracking technologies and why the most popular intervention to protect people, giving them control over whether they attract online and whether their children attract online, may not be the best approach. It feels much more of a burden and a responsibility
所以这就是为什么我觉得这个“探索模式”只是一个选项，它至少让我们能够获得一些集体监督。所以即使我们没有那么频繁地使用它，它仍然意味着我们有一个选择去看看另一边发生了什么。在我们《隐藏的大脑Plus》的配套剧集中，我们审视了数字监控的弊端。我们更仔细地审视了跟踪技术的危害，以及为什么保护人们最流行的干预措施——让他们控制是否在网上被跟踪以及他们的孩子是否在网上被跟踪——可能不是最好的方法。这感觉更像是一种负担和责任，
that we're not really equipped to take on. To listen, please look for the episode titled, How to Protect Yourself Online on HiddenBrain Plus. If you're not yet signed up, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're not yet signed up, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, please go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. Sandra Matz is the author of Mind Masters,
我们并没有真正准备好承担。要收听，请寻找标题为“如何在网上保护自己”（How to Protect Yourself Online）的剧集，在HiddenBrain Plus上。如果你还没有注册，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你还没有注册，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请前往apple.co/hiddenbrain。桑德拉·马茨是《思维大师》的作者，
the data-driven science of predicting and changing human behavior. Sandra, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Burns, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury.
《思维大师：预测和改变人类行为的数据驱动科学》。桑德拉，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·伯恩斯（Autumn Burns）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. Today's story comes from Stephanie Cole. When Stephanie was a teenager, she got her very first job. It was around the winter holidays at a department store in Los Angeles. There I was in my black skirt, my white blouse, and ready to go the first day. And I had been trained but very, very quickly. And as is true in a department store during Christmas, it was just bustling.
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。今天我们以我们姐妹节目《我未被歌颂的英雄》（My Unsung Hero）中的一个故事结束。这个《我未被歌颂的英雄》片段由T-Mobile for Business赞助。今天的故事来自斯蒂芬妮·科尔（Stephanie Cole）。当斯蒂芬妮还是个十几岁的孩子时，她得到了她的第一份工作。那是在洛杉矶一家百货公司的冬日假期前后。第一天，我穿着黑裙子、白衬衫，准备出发了。我接受过培训，但非常、非常快。正如圣诞节期间百货公司的情况一样，那里非常繁忙。
You know how it is at Christmas when everybody's out shopping and everybody's in a hurry? And all these people around, this woman comes up to me with, I think, a Christmas tree ornament she wanted to buy. And I freeze. I just freeze. All of a sudden, I can't remember anything. I can't remember how to run the cash register. I can't remember anything about the transactions. I am just absolutely frozen and probably very close to tears. Just I so wanted this to go right and it was going so wrong. She looked at me and paused and with such a kind expression on her face said,
你知道圣诞节时每个人都在购物，每个人都很匆忙是什么样子吗？周围有这么多人，这个女人带着我想买的圣诞树装饰品走过来。我僵住了。我只是僵住了。突然间，我不记得任何事情了。我不记得怎么操作收银机了。我不记得关于交易的任何事情了。我绝对僵住了，可能快要哭了。我只是非常希望这一切顺利，但结果却非常糟糕。她看着我，停顿了一下，脸上带着非常友善的表情说，
it's all right, take your time, I'm not in a hurry. And that was the release. All of a sudden I could breathe, I could wait till somebody else could help me. It was gonna be okay. It made such an impression that all these years later, not only do I still remember it, but I find myself, those words coming out of my mouth,
没关系，慢慢来，我不赶时间。那就是释放。突然间我可以呼吸了，我可以等到别人能帮我的时候。一切都会好起来的。这给我留下了如此深刻的印象，以至于多年后的今天，我不仅仍然记得它，而且我发现自己，那些话从我的嘴里说出来，
on numerous, many, many occasions over the years. You know, you encounter somebody whose's first day on the job, or they're just having a bad day, and things are really... You can tell they're in a bad place. And you can say, it's okay, I'm not in a hurry, take your time. And it always makes the situation better. Always, always.
多年来在无数、许多、许多场合。你知道，你会遇到第一天上班的人，或者他们只是度过了糟糕的一天，事情真的……你可以看出他们处于糟糕的状态。你可以说，没关系，我不赶时间，慢慢来。这总是让情况变得更好。总是，总是。
And so this woman, I can't really remember her face and certainly she's probably dead by now given how old I was and how old she was. But she gave me that gift without knowing she gave me that gift. And it's lasted all these years. Sangheera podcast or on our website hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以这个女人，我真的记不清她的脸了，而且考虑到我当时多大，她当时多大，她现在可能已经去世了。但她在不知道的情况下给了我那份礼物。而且它持续了这么多年。在播客或我们的网站hiddenbrain.org上。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。